let's say you think very highly if
company ABCD and you're convinced that
the stock price will go up from its
current trading price of $50 per share
its current trading price of $50 you
could do two things you could either
just buy the stock for $50 and hope that
the price goes up or and I made this
price up you could go to an Options
Exchange and for the price of five
dollars
you could buy the option to buy this
stock over the next month it expires in
one month usually will be a specific
date but I'm just saying a 1 month from
the date that you buy the option and it
gives you the option to buy the stock
for $60 a share and the type of option
that I've just described is called
an American option and it can be
compared to a European option an
American option allows you to the to
exercise the option to actually buy the
stock anytime from the time you have the
option until the expiration on a
European option you only have the option
you can only exercise it on the
expiration but we'll just focus on the
American now let's think about the
different outcomes depending on what the
stock does so let's say that the stock
actually does do what you think it does
let's say it goes up and then it goes
down let's say that you're really good
at calling stock at stock price tops and
then right over here let's take the two
scenarios let's take the scenario where
you bought the stock and then you sell
the stock so you bought it 50 and then
over here right at the top you're just a
perfect market caller you are able to
sell the stock at $80 so let's just
think about the different profit
scenarios so here we have an end price
of $80 per share if you had bought the
stock for 50 and now sold it at 80 you
will have a profit of you will have a
profit of $30 now let's think about if
instead of buying the stock you you
bought the option today so if you bought
the option same thing when the stock
goes up to here you'll say oh I think
that's the top for the stock let me
exercise my option so I'm going to
exercise my option which gives me the
right to buy the stock at $60 a share so
you're going to buy it at $60 a share
right
over here and then you could immediately
sell it for $80 a share so you can make
you can make $20 on that transaction but
of course you paid $5 for the option
itself so you make $20 on the difference
between 80 and 60 but you had to pay
five so you have a 15 15 dollar profit
so there it says hey look maybe I was
better off buying the stock and even
there I would say look to buy the stock
that you had to put $50 of capital at
risk to buy the option you only have to
put $5 of capital at risk and to see
that imagine the negative scenario where
instead of the stock doing that let's
say the stock let's say the stock just
completely plummets after you buy it it
goes all the way down to $20 now in the
situation with the stock let's say right
over there you just had enough you just
say I want to sell the stock so this is
an end price this is an end price of $20
in that situation you bought for 50 sell
for 20 you will lose $30 but in the
option scenario this entire time that it
was plummeting you'll say I just won't
exercise the option the option is out of
the money it makes no sense for me to
exercise it so you just won't exercise
the option so you'll only lose the price
that you paid for the option you'll only
lose you'll only lose your $5